Yo ! C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouveau Coup de Phil
"Ce qui ne te tue pas te rend plus fort"
ou encore : "Dieu est mort"
Bref
C'est des citations que vous avez sûrement déjà entendues
et ça tombe bien
Parce qu'on va attaquer
l'un des épisodes les plus demandés
depuis la création de l'émission
il s'agit du surhomme de Nietzsche !
(musique)
Friedrich Wilhelm Nietzsche est un philosophe allemand
Alors il a deux particularités :
Déjà au niveau de son nom
il a toutes les consonnes dedans :
"Nie T Z S Che"
Donc pour l'orthographe c'est plutôt simple hein, vous mettez tout ;
Et ensuite au niveau du physique c'est quoi cette moustache hein ?
Le mec a une moustache plus épaisse que ses cheveux hein
On dirait un balai quoi !
(accent allemand) J'adore les saucisses de Francfort et Heinrich, mon chien !
Il a étudié la Philologie (c'est l'étude d'une langue à partir des textes)
Il est devenu lui même professeur de philolo
"Philolololo lololo lololo, philolololo"
Mais il a pas pu continuer longtemps
parce qu'il avait des maux de têtes à répétition
Genre hyper-violents
Donc il arrête à 35 ans
et là pendant 10 ans
Il donne tout ce qu'il a
Et il publie la majeure partie de ses œuvres
Sachant qu'à ce moment il passe déjà sa vie dans une grande solitude
Et là à 45 ans sa maladie le plonge dans un état critique
genre en mode légume pendant 10 ans
Alors Monsieur Friedrich ? On dit plus rien là hein ?
Alors ça rend plus fort alors ou pas ?
Hein ?
et ouais... et ouais...et ouais
Ah les philosophes je te jure
Nietzsche critique le christianisme
parce que pour lui, ça met la terre en infériorité par rapport au ciel
Et en plus ça nous demande de dépasser ce qui nous semble important sur Terre
Sauf qu'en faisant ça, bah on se détourne un petit peu de la vie elle-même.
En plus de ça, c'est ce que je vous disais dans l'intro:
pour lui, "Dieu est mort"
Alors ça implique pas mal de choses cette mort de Dieu.
Déjà ça veut pas dire que plus personne croit en Dieu hein.
C'est pas ça.
Ça veut juste dire que nos valeurs ne reposent plus sur la foi.
Or l'héritage de notre moral, en tout cas chez nous, il est judéo-chrétien.
C'est à dire qu'il vient de tout ce qui est "tu ne tueras point", etc.
Donc si on perd notre foi, et bien le système va finir par se rompre.
Et on assiste du coups à une dévalorisation des valeurs supérieures
Comme les valeurs de justice, liberté, moralité,  etc...
(Musique d'Église) Mon père, on vient d'apprendre que Dieu est mort !
Mais enfin ! ça fait 40 ans que j'ai donné ma vie pour le Seigneur.
Ouais je sais je sais !
Bref les valeurs du coup ....!
Moi je vais me faire des put** et finir Pokémon !
Ciao !
Mmh  troublant cette histoire.
C-Continue Thomas s'il te plaît.
La conséquence de ça c'est le Nihilisme.
Et c'est pas le fait de croire en rien comme beaucoup pourraient le penser.
Non. Chez Nitszche, il y a deux formes de nihilisme.
Il y a d'abord le nihilisme passif
C'est celui qui considère que la vie n'a pas trop de sens.
Donc il se demande "A quoi bon ?"
C'est celui qui n'a pas la force de croire en autre chose qu'en son propre bonheur.
Tu vois ? Donc c'est un pessimiste.
Et ce nihilisme là, il faut le combattre.
Mais si Dieu est mort et qu'on va perdre nos valeurs,
et bien autant qu'on les perde parce qu'on les remplace par quelque chose.
C'est ce que Nietzsche appelle le nihilisme actif.
Et va nous falloir un petit peu d'aide pour remplacer ces valeurs.
Ouais ? ouais on va remplacer les valeurs. Ouais il y a une dévalorisation
Ouais voilà, exactement, tu vends, tu vends tout tout tout. Ouais.
Ouais exactement. Au niveau de la justice par contre, t'as le cours ?
Non ? Prudence alors.
Prudence.
Du coups il va vouloir revaloriser la vie elle-même, revaloriser l'être.
Il va vouloir rectifier si tu veux, cette inferiorité de la terre par rapport au ciel qu'on a vu tout à l'heure dans le christianisme.
Et en fait il se rend compte que chaque être à une énergie en lui,
qui est moteur, qui le pousse,
et va partir de ça.
C'est la volonté de puissance.
Vous vous souvenez du conatus de Spinoza ?
Alors le conatus c'est l'effort de persévérance dans son être,
C'est genre par exemple la plante qui pousse,
le cheval qui galope,
l'homme qui pense ou qui désire.
La volonté de puissance de Nietzsche c'est très proche,
sauf qu'on est pas dans la persévérance de son être,
mais on est dans le dépassement.
C'est à dire que le but c'est pas de conserver sa puissance,
Mais c'est de l'augmenter indéfiniment.
Et si on va à l'incarnation de cette volonté de puissance,
la plus haute,
la limite vers + ∞ pour les matheux,
on arrive au surhomme.
Alors pourtant j'ai bien suivi la notice,
Mais je suis pas sûr que ça soit la bonne manière pour dépasser mon être.
Mmh je suis pas sur.
Enfin tu me diras, le ridicule ne tue pas hein.
Ce qui ne te tue pas te rend plus fort !
Donc peut-être que le ridicule te rend plus fort...
Ah j'avoue, put*n j'avais pas pensé à ça.
Et là vous en pensez quoi ?
(musique)
Alors le surhomme c'est pas du tout ce qu'on vient de voir hein.
Non le surhomme c'est un idéal pour l'homme, du coup.
L'homme c'est la "corde tendue" entre la bête et le surhomme.
C'est à dire que tout ce qui est naze en toi, c'est la bête.
C'est l'animal.
Et ce que tu veux atteindre, ce que tu dois atteindre, c'est le surhomme.
Alors faut pas du tout le voir comme superman ou un truc surnaturel hein.
Du tout.
C'est quelque chose de très concret.
En voulant être un  surhomme, l'homme se surpasse.
Et pour Nietzsche, c'est ce qui fait de lui un homme.
Autre chose importante,
le surhomme, si tu veux,
il désire pas un monde idéal,
un monde qui pourrait arriver,
qui pourrait exister. Non.
Le surhomme il veut et il consent ce monde.
Notre monde.
Et du coup, il en désire même le retour.
C'est quelque chose qu'on appelle l'éternel retour.
En fait Nietzsche dit qu'il faut vivre sa vie,
de telle sorte qu'on puisse souhaiter
de la vivre indéfiniment.
C'est déjà relou avec un iPod, alors je te laisse imaginer avec la vie...
Après ça peut être très cool !
Euh continue Thomas s'il te plaît.
Mais ça peut être aussi très nul.
Hein ?
Mais non ça va pas durer longtemps !
Allez ! Penchez-vous en avant là !
Voilà !
Donc, ce qu'il faut, c'est voir cette idée de l'éternel retour comme
une épreuve à passer pour savoir si on se rapproche ou pas du surhomme.
Le surhomme c'est donc l'accomplissement de la volonté de puissance,
et de l'éternel retour.
On peut voir le surhomme comme un destination,
la volonté de puissance comme notre moteur,
et l'éternel retour comme la route que l'on prend.
Alors attention le surhomme il va donc nous aider à remplacer les valeurs dont on parlait,
mais il remplace pas vraiment Dieu !
Parce que le suhomme, si tu veux, il est pas au-delà de notre réalité.
Le surhomme c'est un idéal concret,
en tout homme, sur terre.
Mais maman ça veut dire qu'il existe vraiment superman ?
Mais bien sûr mon chéri, il est en toi !
Au plus profond de ton être !
Cool !
Après cette conversation, Jayson est mort
suite à une chute violente de plusieurs étages,
croyant pouvoir voler.
Son corps s'est ensuite fait écraser à plusieurs reprises par des camions poubelles
et le bus numéro 128.
Et d'ailleurs si tu veux augmenter ta volonté de puissance,
et te dépasser,
je te conseille de t'abonner à la chaîne et de ne rater aucun épisode à venir.
J'espère en tout cas que le surhomme de Nietzsche est maintenant plus clair pour vous,
je vous envoie du Love et de la Peace,
(Bisou)
(cri) YALLAH
(musique) Je remercie aussi Jonathan qui est derrière le blog "Un Philosophe"
qui d'ailleurs à l'heure où je vous parle,
normalement a sorti il y a pas longtemps
un article sur Nietzsche aussi.
et qui est spécialiste de Nietzsche
ce qui m'a permis d'être sûr de la qualité de cette épisode.
Autre chose, souvent quand on parle de Nietzsche, on évoque le Nazisme,
en fait ce qui s'est passé,
c'est que les Nazi ont utilisé Nietzsche pour défendre leur idéologie,
notamment avec l'idée de surhomme par exemple,
en parlant d'un surhomme physique,
alors que Nietzsche finalement avait plus l'idée d'un surhomme intellectuel,
Alors évidemment le Nazisme c'est quelque chose qu'aurait condamné Nietzsche,
Par exemple il était pote avec Wagner,
et il a arrête d'être pote à partir du moment ou celui-ci est devenu antisémite.
Voilà.
Oubliez pas de me suivre sur les réseaux sociaux aussi,
Euh, Facebook, Twitter, Snapchat,
Les trois je les utilise différemment,
Facebook c'est plus de temps en temps une grosse news,
Twitter comme ça..
et Snapchat... bah ceux qui me suivent le savent.
Plein de chose ! Voilà.
Mouais je suis pas sûr.
Enfin tu me diras le ridicule ne tue pas hein.
Ce qui ne tue pas rend plus fort.
du coup....
ce qui rend ridicule...
(rires)